like to convict the man no I'll just
turn up my shirt I was rubbing hopes I
was I was definitely rub I just saw
wrinkles I wanted to unwrinkle I saw
wrinkles - hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm back once again with
Wade here say hi Wade sing defeat of the
last game what we saw I did I messed up
the same damn partner they did before
anyway we saw the different developers
is the word the developer made another
game along the same vein of complexity
so our stupid brains should be able to
comprehend it and I should be able to
beat him in the same game this one's
called tug the table how hard can this
be longer legs in me it's not winning
I'm not how are you winning no it did
pop off why did it was slippery what
does it even mean oh no no no
[Music]
[Music]
you better at me are you better in me
[Applause]
I'm like horizontal
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna flip you floppy here you go
W I'm gonna go I'm gonna go up okay
you're waiting three two one now oh well
we'll switch back okay watch this that
wasn't [ __ ] no wait with I do it
again and if I win then you're gonna win
yes well I doesn't seem fair at all when
you switch back W no no no no no no no
no no no wait a minute why do I want to
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't be better than I'm so better
at this up this uh no but no no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you infused with my packing with
your magical now I want it back
no you can't have it back baloney
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now we have no head well you did it in
what way does that make it any different
it affects it affects the durability of
our ability no it's not decides you're
gonna win balls it all comes down to
this this one finally orange but I mean
whatever you know ready to lose do it oh
I am the best
I'm just the best I mean I'm gonna edit
out all the times I'll just take my big
head I just I was hustling you the
entire time
and what you didn't realize
oh god this is not good no oh if you
make some amazing comeback after this
[Music]
[Applause]
one more for all the marbles three out
of five is that what we're doing it's
two to two and song song song song god I
messed up that joke I was right there in
my hands the dong yes joke but I mean
also the dong where'd it go in my song
he lost his dog lost it last round to
prove who's truly the best my big head
if you didn't know about it I have the
biggest head around good you're correct
what how dare you sir
how dare you how dare you tell me about
the dong and Fung I lost him no no I
don't know suddenly got so bad I don't
know what hello Twinkle Toes gonna win
that's what I said in the beginning let
me just cut in a quick clip of me saying
those exact words in the beginning by
pure luck
okay it's skill all right you want
playing one more on up and sometimes you
need to do fast sometimes you need to
slow like when you get vertical I think
you okay not everything has to be sexual
is when you get vertical you want to get
horizontal so you need to make really
fast thrusts right that's what the crack
comes in that's when you get oh no don't
get it lost in the thong with in the
dong and the thong the dog in the dock
dog in the song in the dong hey don't
ask no he's a dog my dog the dog on the
dog and the the frog with the dog on a
thong no the frog with the dong the
father the dog ill thong the frog with
the dog was it wrong shut up I'm trying
to get it the frog with the dong and
then the frog with the dong with the dog
in the song on the log in a crack in the
back and the lock in the buck in the
hole in the bottom of the sea the frogs
all get in the hog in the bag of the
crack of the hole the bottom of
I don't know where we went from hugging
a table to talk about a frog in a thong
with a dong and a dog hit single hit
single it's gonna be the only hit cuz
they're gonna kill us afterwards cause
perfection you can't beat it with a to
stop us before me I don't think we said
the same verse of it twice anyway game
here yeah I already pressed it all or
nothing okay yeah yeah oh you're
learning oh you're learning computer
oh you're learning oh you're learn about
that much no get over the line no no
over the line No
Blanc don't know what the plank does Hey
many big heads blanks our heads are
normal size but we're amid anybody's got
any beady little eggs just gotta give it
to me I'm not gonna even try you want to
give it to you never mind
they're good to win and then mock you
yes you do then come on I'm ready I'm
ready
[Applause]
oh-oh-oh-oh time marker glare will you
there could not possibly be another dam
made by this guy with one button there
is less coming later I got a record that
in a different episode yeah anyway thank
you all so much for watching then you
wait for being here and as always we
will see you in the next video we going
on off beats here yes okay oh we just
need one clean one that I can loop it
okay just try to do exactly the same
movement just one clean alternating
movement
[Music]
okay